m
ils
disent elles
danse avec les stars tu es payé combien
pour faire mon sac est à mille euros
c'est le tarif à peu près pour tout le
monde bon d'accord vous pouvez avoir 80
ou 120 mais on est sur 100000 euros à
peu près la publicité entre je dois dire
excusez moi j'ai fait six semaines de
prime + 4 semaines avant donc dix
semaines très intenses je ne dis pas que
ça vous ça vaut 100 mille euros mais je
dis que c'est pas non plus une petite
rue non bien sûr non non non pas du tout
fait dix semaines de ma vie loin de ma
famille loin de ma fille
ma plus grosse gaffe alors j'ai eu au
début des moments de solitude parce que
j'inventais des mots me voilà ça sortait
votre esprit quand on a peur c'était
dans le film d'une il ya une réplique je
parle de l'ancien film d'une parce que
je suis un peu vieilli mais la peur tu
l'esprit et ben c'est vrai en fait quand
vous comprenez que la peur tu l'esprit
vais essayer de dompter votre peur et
donc quand vous avez peur vous êtes
capable de voilà de sortir des mots qui
n'existent pas dans le dictionnaire donc
ça c'était mes petites gaffes de départ
ça le téléphone sonne dans une maison et
un petit garçon qui décroche
à l'eau 0e bonjour martin et dit oui et
10 bompas mois sans papa gay pas le prêt
pass et ils ont occupé i lé ballon passe
moi maman kim à moi je peux pas aller
occuper du papa sera ton frère alors ai
dit je peux pas y occuper mais il ya
qu'il dans la maison et dubai la police
qui quoi la police mais pas ça moi et
guaino il sera occupé
mais ils sont occupés à faire quoi qui
bat il cherche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]